Hi, everybody. Ashley here. I will be discussing our weight loss and bundle that we have here.
So it's really neat. Each particular supplement, we have four of them, work together in your
weight loss journey. So the first one is going to be our uptight balancer. This is going to be
containing natural amino acids to help with your carb cravings, your neurotransmitter elevations,
and then also suppress your appetite, so a naturally occurring appetite suppressor.
This one works really well with our leptin balancer, which is our next product.
Leptin is actually going to be our hormonal component of weight loss, which gets really missed.
So leptin receptors are going to be what signals your body when it's hungry or full. If your receptors
are turned off, you don't know in your fault. So you're consuming more food. This is going to
balance that out and let your body know, hey, we're full. We don't need any more food over here.
Leptin balancer. Then we have the proviol clear lean. This is going to be your probiotic.
Everyone's on a probiotic, I feel like, but you can definitely compare this to maybe the one that
you're on. This one is going to be introducing new microbiome to your gut and then help with your
gut flora in general, and then it also promotes the weight loss component. We then have our SPI protect.
This is going to be the gut healer piece of this little bumpil here. So you want your gut healed.
So then everything that you introduce into it works so much efficiently. So everything will then
search for work better. Then if your gut is still leaky and everything can just kind of come in
and not really be utilized or absorbed even. So SPI protect is your gut healer. You can find all
for these products on shop.conorsclinic.com and you can search weight loss bundle. You can then
from there, click on each individual product on its own and it will give you more information on that
product as well as some research, which is great to back up what you are purchasing. It gives you an
idea of what has gone into the product and how it is actually going to be effective for you and your
goals. So I really hope this helps your weight loss journey and feel free to contact the clinic if
you need further information. Thank you.